hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to leave now this is a
save point I knew this I knew this
before and I even saw this particular
save point in the last game that I
played but to get to it you needed to go
to the side here crawl through wait no
not here here oh it's closed down now
but you needed to go to the side and
crawl through a tiny crawlspace over
here so that you get to it and there's a
bear trap value right there I don't know
how I didn't touch that one there are a
lot of air traps just lurking in the
darkness I don't know why and I don't
know where but they're going to find me
and they're going to bite me in the butt
so I finally saved and apparently the
developers even said this this is the
only way you can save - a few level
transition auto-saves
now I don't really like that I made my
case in the last episode but I can't
fault them for me not doing the
mechanics I wasn't aware that I needed
to go through a secret path when I saw
that I thought the ladder up might have
gotten me there and the drop down seemed
like it might have dropped down into
this point where the save point was so I
I want to kind of apologize coming down
heavy ended but I kind of don't because
it's kind of a little bit yeah but
anyway I was naive back then her husband
Jacob was ferocious beyond compare but
foolish as I was I kept pushing my luck
the man was great influence on the
village silent whispers described him as
a merciless man we had no other choice
but have our meetings in utmost secrecy
but it wasn't long enough but it wasn't
enough our hearts kept longing for more
and so we became lovers well this is an
interesting tale of adultery let also I
had to go down here and replace it it
was a puzzle in and of itself I had to
go down there get a power supply and put
it back up here and find a way to get it
back up so with all that being said we
have made progress we are going forward
and now I need to go back because I need
to go up the ladder over here and this
ladder you can see how I might have been
misled into thinking that this was gonna
go up and then drop down into that room
because it looked like it was gonna
because I was going over here and this
see
oh yeah this was the bear trap room I
didn't remember I hit them all over
again because I'm a big dumb fool and
then coming over here like in my mind
this was kind of close to where that
room was but apparently not and I
I am forlorn and I have to go through
this again
but the reason I'm starting it here now
is because I have done the save and that
way if I die on this chase that's about
to happen it won't be the end of the
world it'll be the end of my world and
I'll be very upset but it won't be the
end of the world yes that's good okay so
this is gonna leave me over here now now
the other thing that I don't know I
don't know see that's where I died
because the floor collapsed now I don't
know if I was supposed to go that way
like was I supposed to go that way am I
just not supposed to ever go where
something tells me I can escape because
otherwise I was gonna die to the monster
so I was being routed yep that is like
that huh it's like that okay so it's
behind me
and it's coming after me but I'm not
supposed to go [ __ ] well that's no good
oh [ __ ] oh I do oh damn it what do I do
why can't I go now what's happening I
thought I could go here Oh am I gonna
die oh hey friend oh you want to be
friends I've got a peace offering I'll
chop off a piece of my butt and give it
to you because I don't actually have
anything besides a lot of drugs okay
sorry
whoa jeez okay so we try going a laugh
how about this yeah this looks good okay
so that's not it but this is the way
that killed me isn't it looks like death
it's
oh it wasn't supposed to kill me
oh okay so that wasn't supposed to
actually kill me
I was forsaken Oh was it was beat was it
because I was low on health or something
ooh
we're in the pit of bones now do I want
to know where these came from because
once again I want to comment on the
illogical nosov where we are considering
this was a mine and now it seems like a
castle dungeon I mean I know I got
knocked out back there but I don't think
I went far enough to go into the
catacombs under France I should prolly
move
I think monsters are still after me but
the sheer quantity of bones is very
concerning in the fact that they're
using it as carpeting it's just a little
disgraceful disrespectful oh I I can
open that can I
the disfigured man carried me all the
way down here and locked me up inside
that filthy old cell was I supposed to
wait for someone I should have left the
island when I had the chance
your gosh Dan darn right you shoulda
nothing you had a chance yeah I didn't
really have a boat I mean I guess you
could have gone back instead of going
further deep down into the mines like a
fool so now we have what more bones
could God it's an endless stream of
bones where else am I suppose it go
it's my friend boney gonna pop up out of
here gonna teach me to be to blow again
I don't know okay mmm like this you know
likey but me going
I don't like that I don't like that I
just played re 77 in it only bad things
came out of a woman crying in the
distance oh boy yeah that ain't good
what's that woo
what the Frick just happen to me well I
don't know but something did there's
someone in there hello just cry 2 times
if you're in trouble I can't tell sounds
like a lot I can't see anything
yeah okay so I don't see a way through
everything's locked up and there's no
doors ah here we go
I stand corrected whoo it's quiet here
why am I here what am i doing why am i
doing it where did I come from
where did I go okay okay I feel like a
rat in a maze and I'm just being led
around like a stupid but okay [ __ ]
alrighty then
this has got to be Frick sassafras so
many going backs oh there are how did I
miss that
why was that there of all the places to
put this you can only get to it if you
had magical powers let's see we're
relying on that and then there are
making we come through they counted on
me finding that barrel of goo down in
the mush man [ __ ] there I go going off
on my tangents in boo hey are you the
crying lady I don't think you're fun I
don't think I don't think you're gonna
help me I don't think I was supposed to
fall down here anybody got any food oh
good I was hoping for a tasty juicy leg
the melody keeps ringing in my ears long
after the needle comes to an end
as if my mind thirst for more I know now
how this will end but first I will need
have a word with everyone they are so
eager dad hear my story
oh is this why everyone has been turned
into bones ah
good great maybe you freed them from the
curse of the skeleton living inside them
did you know you all have a skeleton
living inside you how cool is science or
biology whatever how cool is that creepy
fact okay oh this is where I am now it
did okay
ah good year old kid ABS oh yeah there
we go I keep forgetting that I I fill up
on the magic juice definitely a lot more
than I do anything else so alright time
to go say hi to the crying lady hello
okay
what happened oh hi how are you what are
you doing whoa what are you doing what
are you doing all right I'm coming over
there oh that's not what I wanted to do
was it oh I don't think I was supposed
to do that
I don't think I wanted to free you I
don't trust you if you're the only
living thing in a sea of bones I I kind
of know who the culprit is right then oh
oh I shouldn't do this
oh this bad oh I thought this I thought
this was leading over to her boy okay
just empty cells all righty then don't
mind me I just freed you it's just
stupid oh hello is this way I was
supposed to go without falling like him
oh so scary okay random guillotine
jump-scare i guess is better than a bear
trap you wouldn't think there'd be any
bear traps lurking amongst these
skeletons woods yet ooh oh you're dead
okay good I mean not good for you but
good for me because I don't want to deal
with the living is there no end to this
darkness are we alone where is everyone
why has he left me alive this place is
calling me I can feel it
finally my mind is at rest your mind is
at rest when the floor is bone
okey-dokey then whatever you say mr. or
miss whoever you may have written that
I'm not entirely sure who Oh No Oh No
oh she's gone oh she's gone oh she's
gone oh no oh no oh no oh no oh no oh no
I got nothing else to say besides a
whole no cuz just bad shit's bad yo I
mean she's gonna be stalking around the
halls now okay well you know maybe I'm
maybe I'm operating under the wrong
assumption maybe she's actually good
maybe she's gonna be super kind to me
maybe everything's gonna be great we're
gonna have a fun time and swap stories
braid each other's hair steal each
other's boyfriends hmm don't like that
where could she have gone don't eat it
hmm yeah I know I'm a big [ __ ] shut up
it's not about women just terrify me
yeah I can't talk to him I just freeze
up what happened to my kabob
give me my kebabs I need help real bad
oh okay
okay
right how's that duo everybody's coming
after mate I guess I just still take a
chair pulls it off
Oh shitty dicks oh I'm [ __ ] yeah
oh that's not good huh I know right
life's horrible oh is that mean she's
aging okay okay so far so goo Oh back to
technology huh oh not yet though we got
to find a way to open this douche okay
so how do we open no this is a hidey
hole it's a good Heidi what is that what
you're trying to do you need to go
deeper in the throat to be able to sing
that song
what wait isn't this down the honey hole
Oh God back side it was the [ __ ] did
that no I thought it was a hidey hole it
was just a pillar of boxes and I was all
around the wrong side like an idiot I'm
all the way back here coz the lovely
save mechanic system is awesome I did it
again I did it again why is that like
that why is that like that owner how
many of their playtesters just took a
dive down that remind the only one ok
I'm back to where I need to be and I
hear a save point somewhere over here I
just don't know if I can get to it
I don't know if it's gonna be kind to me
like that I don't think it is I don't
think it wants to be kind to me like
that
I think it wants me to survive and not
die like an idiot because apparently one
hit from this lady is go
okay she's gonna come down this hallway
here okay there she is okay so then
we're just gonna skedaddle around not
mess with her at all
Joe Bonnie no brand deals in this one
yeah okay so I got to find a way I think
I've gone around I think I got some
hidey holes over here but I gotta find
something that can come on kidding me
there's got to be something over here
yeah what is that did I do his oven
would that do I don't know what that did
but maybe oh did that open the door
could it really be that simple
oh she is can you scream for me
so I know where you is okay okay okay
okay so far so goo can I block that off
gonna get get get get okay there we go
Wow look at that who the hell built this
down here huh okay I'm gonna go back
because I know there's a save point
around here somewhere I heard the static
there's gotta be one right
also why man someone's been slacking on
the cleanup duty after these cremations
because other no time for that
it's got to be a way to get to it over
here or something because otherwise I am
going to be very pissed because I
couldn't find it and that's oddly
punishing if I can't find the same point
that there's a big artistic rendering of
a vagina oh that's a trap oh that's a
trap oh that's a trap oh that's hello
who's there that's such a trap it's a
trap it's a trap you trap
I know trap what I said trap okay
trap oh it's not a trap oh it's the
opposite of trap that's exactly what I
love [ __ ] you hey tan dicks EE 10x where
are the rest of you sacks of [ __ ] okay
far so goo just don't trap me ah there
you are
bear jobs can't believe I have to be so
minutely aware of them the man just
keeps dancing endlessly inside my head
without mercy I can't take it anymore
and yet here I am still waiting for
words to fill the next lines I think
that means you're out
find I saved and yet it's not time to
end the episode just yet hello down
there well that's convenient for dumping
bodies okay so this which was obviously
a trap and I still say it was a trap
because of the bear trap what was I
gonna say I have no idea I was just
trying to complain don't mind me I'm
just complaining that's me mister
complain boy hello that almost killed me
thank you
alright why does this remind me a Legend
of Zelda all right goodbye
boink hello hello goodbye anybody home
oh you are a thing yeah man
so in Kitson you can't throw these in oh
you can well it didn't work before so
why did it work this time physics system
being all inconsistent and [ __ ] okay
maybe I'm just getting weak or maybe I'm
just getting stronger you never know
okay so there's got to be a way to get
up right I imagine because they put so
many boxes and in such wonderful
stacking shapes I'm guessing that I need
to stack and/or climb just like that
okay hip okay
huh so we got in my eye ah Oh God
like a bug just lura in my eye holy [ __ ]
oh wow I don't know what the hell just
went in my eye cuz it's not like there's
a swarm of gnats flying around my face
but holy [ __ ] did a spider drop from the
ceiling and landed in my eye
alright anyway don't mind me just
getting emotional about this game so
emotionally invested hey oh wait no
let's go up here is that what I'm
supposed to do hey okay so what now
okay oh well that's good that's awfully
nice so I need to drag another son [ __ ]
up here maybe just take this sumbitch
put it there Hobbit a husky Hobbit abou
ski I'm happy okay anybody else anybody
else want to tango why did I suddenly
start crouching
all right you did I don't know if I'm
supposed to be up here head of key hit
it oh well that seems safe okay bye
thanks for the help
all right on my way oh good at least I'm
lighting my path though that all the
monsters will be able to follow me and
murder me and know exactly where I go
and be able to follow me all the way
back home trust that all right so I
don't trust that direction at all
because that's back towards where the
lady was as pretty as she probably is I
see I see maybe I could have used this
to break it in see it didn't work that
time did there we go Kabam come back
come back to bed okay anything else okay
so are we good here oh god damn it of
course that's gonna be not the way that
I'm supposed to go all right then back
this way back towards the lady who cares
what's in that weird castle that someone
built on the ground let's go straight
down this hallway it's definitely
comforting mmm bones it's the sign of
the woman know where she is but she's
close by okay oh another safe another
same point whoa oh no this one's not
powered oh I gotta find a way to power
it well that's inconvenient thank you
for that so where's the power supply on
our stamina so where's the power supply
someone through here it's a lot of
cables okay well there's one there's
something else I got to do oh we needs
to okay this is dead well where am I
gonna find one of those why didn't I
just put them in my back pocket from the
start oh I can see outside and what is
it pumping in water maybe for a steam
engine of sorts I don't know
I gotta go hunt it down cuz obviously
it's not here damn it I'm not gonna be
able to save and then somehow I know I'm
gonna die
I just have a funny feeling okay
alright here we go
I just want to save huh thank you oh
good okay
got it yeah damnit there we go okay
Kimmy ABS finally I'm gonna be back to
full health
there's probably something under there
still I just can't reach it is it a
kebab ah [ __ ] dude okay want to get it
oh you [ __ ] kak
well I'm building a fort under there god
damn it okay fine [ __ ] you physics all
right with holy prayer I gaze at the
starry sky pure sacred lights and
children of the night banish all
darkness and grant us light alas there
is no hope left we are condemned to
forever walk in the shadows we feast
upon the forbidden fruit in our despair
our prayers now forever echoing like
drops of ink and a bottomless sea well
that was beautiful but what did it mean
what is it pertaining to in your current
situation your current predicament of
death man I don't know what happened to
these people but it has something to do
with this material that they were fine
to get this energy source that I've got
carrying with me like something in it is
either evil or mutating in some capacity
but I'm not sure which or how wink but
doesn't matter because I'm finally gonna
be able to save house key all right
there we go so that is all the time I
got for this episode here I will
officially stop ragging on the save the
mechanics you know I I'm playing the
game and I do enjoy the game it is very
good and it is quite scary like that
lady down there that was a really nice
touch and I bet she's horrifying when
you get up close not that I saw her she
kind of stabbed me up the butt so thank
you everybody so much for watching and
as
always I'll see you in the next video Oh